un vaccin pour traiter et guérir du
cancer
l'idée a de quoi donner espoir à ceux et
celles qui sont infligées par la maladie
il est grâce aux récentes découvertes du
docteur claude perron et son équipe
un vaccin contre le cancer semble bien
en voie de devenir réalité
quand je dis vaccin je veux dire vaccin
thérapeutique vac c'est pour utilisé
pour traiter un cancer existants et non
un vaccin préventif comme ce à quoi on
est habitué le docteur claude perron et
chercheur principal à l'institut de
recherche en immunologie et en
cancérologie lié à l'université de
montréal lui et son équipe travaillent
depuis des années pour trouver un remède
contre le cancer depuis une dizaine
d'années il ya de plus en plus de
preuves que notre système immunitaire
veut éliminer des cellules cancéreuses
si on stimule les cellules immunitaires
on peut augmenter la réponse contre le
cancer
alors la grande question qui se pose
c'est ok les cellules immunitaires que
reconnaît stèle qui leur permet
d'éliminer les cellules cancéreuses pour
l'équipe du docteur perrot il fallait
donc trouver l'élément qui allait forcer
le système immunitaire a débusqué puis à
éliminer les cellules cancéreuses
ça fait déjà je dirais plusieurs années
que tout le monde cherche à trouver les
molécules sur les cellules cancéreuses
qui sont reconnus par d'estimer le cnda
et qu'on n'y arrive pas le docteur
perrot et son équipe ont donc cherché là
où personne n'avait encore osé
s'aventurer estime qu'à peine 2 % de
notre adn est vraiment utile
des chercheurs de l'iréc ont fait un
pari audacieux ils ont fouillé dans le
92 8% adn qu'on croyait inutile ils ont
fouillé dans ce qu'on appelle l'adn
poubelles fallait juste avoir le courage
puis développé des instruments pour
chercher là en fouillant dans l'adn
poubelles l'équipe de lyrique a
découvert ce que d'autres recherches
depuis des années ils ont identifié ce
qu'on appelle des antigènes et ces
antigènes cancéreux sont capables de
stimuler le système immunitaire
non seulement ces antigènes quand serait
capable de stimuler le système
immunitaire mais il était capable
de provoquer une réponse suffisamment
fortes pour faire régresser une tumeur
ce qu'on soit si d'environ trois à
pouvoir commencer une étude clinique de
phase 1 où on va tester des vaccins chez
des patients atteints de cancer
autrement incurable on prend la séquence
codant pour le peptide on le regarde
dans le protéome depuis cette importante
découverte
l'équipe du docteur perrot dresse ce
répertoire des antigènes pour chaque
type de cancer il y en a aucun si
pierrick mans nous semble intraitable
grâce au docteur perrot et à son équipe
de chercheurs l'espoir de vaccins contre
le cancer semble bien près de se
réaliser ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal